hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss permutation
operators in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics
as the name suggests permutation
operators exchange particles with each
other but why do we care about
exchanging particles
when we study systems of many identical
particles
from atoms to molecules to materials
then when we exchange
any two particles the physics stays
exactly the same
the mathematics to describe these
multi-particle systems needs to capture
this symmetry on the particle exchange
and it is precisely what permutation
operators allow us to do
so let's learn about them to study
permutation operators we need to start
by looking at what the permutation is
loosely speaking a permutation is a
rearrangement of a sequence of ordered
elements
to look at a concrete example let's
consider permutation of the three
elements
the permutation is typically represented
by the symbol p
then we list the elements one two and
three in order
and the permutation rearranges these
elements to for example this new order
three one two to illustrate what we're
doing let's place three boxes like this
and let's label them box 1 box 2 and box
3.
then let's place a red ball inside box 1
a green ball
inside box 2 and the blue ball inside
box 3.
this is our starting point here so what
does the permutation 312 here tell us
it tells us to place the boxes again but
now in the order three
one two after this we place the balls as
they were
first red then green and then blue
so in this language the permutation
tells us how to rearrange the boxes
we can view the same permutation from a
different point of view in which we
rearrange the balls rather than the
boxes
let's start by insisting that the three
boxes
are ordered one two three like at the
very beginning
in this language the first entry tells
us to take the ball in box one
in this case the red one to box three so
we place it there
then the second entry tells us to take
the ball in box two
the green one to box one so he place it
there
and the third entry tells us to take the
ball in box three the blue one
to entry two so we place it there
these two interpretations of a
permutation are entirely equivalent
you can see how at the end box 1 has the
green ball in both cases
box 2 has the blue ball in both cases
and box 3 has the red ball in both cases
feel free to use whichever way of
thinking works best for you
as we will see in a moment when we talk
about quantum states of multi-particle
systems
the boxes represent the state space
associated with the particle
and the balls represent the specific
state in which that particle
is these two wheels then become
equivalent to the statement that the
order doesn't matter in a tensor product
before we move on we will simplify the
notation for permutations to capital p
and then the subindex 312 only
specifying the
end position because we will always take
the initial position to be ordered as 1
to 3
so there is no need to specify it every
single time
this id is generalized to permutations
over any number of elements
and for n elements there are n factorial
possible permutations
to move from permutations to permutation
operators let's stick with the case n
equals three
consider a tensor product state space v
of three particles
and construct the bases for this space
in the usual manner using the tensor
product
there are six permutations of three
elements and we can explicitly write
these six permutations of three elements
like this
we are now ready to define the
permutation operators associated with
these six permutations by their action
on basis states
the permutation operator p mnp
acting on the basis state ui1 uj2 uk3
is by definition equal to uim
ujn ukp
what we're doing is moving the particle
associated with state space v1
to state space vm the particle
associated with state space v2
to state space vn and the particle
associated with state space v3
to state space vp this interpretation is
equivalent to the one we discussed
earlier in which we are moving the boxes
so that boxes are equivalent to state
spaces
balls are equivalent to states u and you
should convince yourself that you can
also view the action of the permutation
operator as moving the balls
let's consider p123 as an example it
acts
on the basis state then we write the
state in the same order without the
state space label
and then the sequence one two three
tells us to write one 2 3 here
essentially nothing changes when we
apply p1 to 3 so it is in fact the
identity operator
if we look instead at p231 and again
consider the action on a basis state
then we first write the states and then
the sequence 2 3 1 tells us to write 2
3 1 here remember that the order doesn't
matter in the tensor product as long as
we identify each state with the correct
single particle state space
so we can rewrite this as uk1 ui2
uj3 if you try to go from the original
state here
directly to this state here you will see
that it is equivalent to moving the
balls in the demonstration we started
with
as you can imagine for an n-particle
system we define the corresponding
n-factorial permutation operators in a
similar fashion
the next definition that we need is that
of a transposition
a transposition is a permutation that
exchanges two elements
and leaves the rest invariant sticking
with the n equals three case let's write
out again
all six elements in this example
p132 is a transposition because it
exchanges two and three but leaves one
invariant and you should convince
yourself that p213
and p3 to 1 are also transpositions
by contrast the other three elements are
not transpositions for example we have
already seen that p1 to 3 is the
identity operator
so it isn't a transposition because it
doesn't exchange any elements
transpositions have some nice properties
first
they are hermitian second they are
involutary which means that they are
their own inverses
and third combining the first two
properties means that transpositions are
unitary
to prove these three properties of
transposition we're going to use the
simplest possible transposition as an
example
coming from a two particle system with n
equals two
for equals two we only have two possible
permutations p12
and p21 p12 is the identity
so it is not a transposition p21 is the
operator that exchanges the two
particles
which means it is a transposition what
we're going to do is to use p21 as an
example transposition
to prove these general properties of
transpositions
the first property is that p to 1 is
involutary
this means that it squares to the
identity operator or put another way it
is its own inverse
to see this consider the action of p21
squared on a basis state
we apply the first p to one to exchange
the particles once
and then we apply the second p to one to
exchange the particles back
comparing this term here with this term
here we confirm that p to one squares to
one
in other words exchanging two particles
twice leaves us back where we started
the second property is that it is
hermitian so that p21 dagger is equal to
p21
to see this consider the matrix element
of p21 between two basis states
acting with p21 on these basis states we
obtain this permutation
we can then calculate the scalar product
in the usual way by combining the states
in v1
and the state in v2 and we get this
now consider the matrix element of the
adjoint operator p21
dagger we know that the adjoint operator
acts on the bra
so we obtain the permutation of the bra
we can then calculate the scalar product
again and we get this
these two expressions are the same so
p21 dagger is equal to p21
the third property is that p21 is
unitary so that p21 dagger equals the
inverse of p21
this actually follows trivially from the
first two properties as the operator is
both hermitian and its own inverse
i will not go on but essentially these
three properties generalize to
transpositions for any n
and the proofs work in exactly the same
way as they work for p21
now that we know about permutations and
transpositions we come to a very
important observation
every permutation operator can be
written as a product of transposition
operators
i will not prove this statement but
instead use a permutation
p312 which corresponds to n equals 3 as
an example
note that p312 is itself not a
transposition because it affects all
three elements
to illustrate this i will use boxes and
balls again and now i will take the view
of moving the balls
so that the boxes are always fixed in
the order one two three as such i will
emit the box indices for simplicity and
simply draw the three boxes as shown
here
i picked the initial configuration of
the balls as red green
blue then applying the permutation
p312 moves the ball in box 1 the red
ball
to box 3 so red here then the ball in
box 2
the green one to box 1 so green here
and then the ball in box 3 the blue one
to box two
so blue here let's go back to the
original configuration here
i can reach the same answer by first
applying p3 to one
which is a transposition because it
exchanges one and
three but lives to invariant
and then i can apply another
transposition p213 which
exchanges one and two but leaves three
invariant
this final configuration is the same we
got here so we can write p312 as the
product over these two transpositions
this decomposition is not unique let's
set up the initial configuration again
we can do the same by first applying the
p213 transposition that exchanges 1 and
2
and leaves 3 invariant and then the p132
transposition that exchanges 2 and 3
and leaves 1 invariant this means that
p312 is also equal to this
okay let's set up the initial
configuration yet again we can now apply
p132 then
p213
then p132
and then p213 and we get to the same
answer
this means that p312 is also equal to
this product of four transpositions
we see that we can have different
numbers of transpositions for a given
permutation for example here we have two
and here we have four it turns out that
for a given permutation
the parity of the number of
transpositions is fixed
for example for p312 we can only have an
even number of transpositions
two transpositions in these two examples
or four in this one
but you could never have a naught number
of transpositions for p312
the parity of the number of
transpositions in which you can write
down a given permutation
is called the parity of the permutation
so pc12 is an even permutation
now that we know that the permutation
can be written as a product over
transpositions we can use the properties
of transpositions to figure out a few
additional properties of permutations
to do this we will consider a general
permutation p alpha
where alpha is simply a label to
identify a permutation
so for example in the case of n equals
three can take any of the six sequences
of numbers that provide the six
corresponding permutations
in a similar fashion i will specify
transpositions as t beta
the first property is that permutations
like transpositions are unitary
to see this write the permutation p
alpha
as a product over n transpositions
then calculate the adjoint of the
permutation p alpha dagger
which is equal to the product of the
entrance positions old dagger
we know from the properties of the
adjoint operator that this gives the
adjoints of the terms in the product in
reverse order like this
additionally because transpositions are
unitary each t beta dagger is equal to t
beta minus one
so we can write this as the reverse
product of inverses of the
transpositions
we now ready to calculate the product of
the adjoint permutation with the
permutation itself
it gives this long product of terms
and in this long product the
transpositions come together in the
middle with their inverse because we
reverse the order when calculating the
adjoint
this term gives the identity then these
two terms come together and also combine
to give the identity
and repeating this for all of them
sequentially leads to an overall
identity
this implies that p alpha dagger is the
inverse of p alpha so indeed all
permutations are unitary
so does this result make sense the
inverse of a permutation is given by
applying the sequence of transpositions
in reverse order
and this is exactly what the adjoint
here does
second important property of
permutations is that unlike
transpositions which are hermitian
a general permutation may not be
hermitian
to see this we start with the adjoint of
the permutation
then we pick this result up here for the
adjoint and use the fact that
transpositions are hermitian
to write the adjoint of the permutation
like this
but transpositions don't commute in
general so we cannot rearrange this
sequence to get back to the original
sequence for a general permutation
this implies that general permutations
may not be her mission
the final property is that the adjoint
of a permutation has the same parity as
the original permutation
this is easy to see because we have
shown up here that the adjoint of a
permutation is simply the same sequence
of transpositions
in reverse order so there are as many
transpositions in the adjoint
as in the original permutation a word of
warning
the final two slides include some
advanced ideas that come from group
theory
which is actually one of the reasons why
i think today's video is particularly
exciting
if you've encountered group theory
before and you love it great you'll
enjoy these last two slides
if you haven't don't worry i will
explain everything that you need to know
here
so you'll be able to follow the
reasoning and you'll get the first taste
of group theory
the last feature of permutations i want
to look at is that the collection of all
permutations for a given
n form a group we can look again at the
n equals 3 case to exemplify this
very briefly for a group we need first
an identity
and we have already seen that the
identity is p1 to 3 for n equals 3.
second we need that the product of two
group elements gives another group
element
you can explicitly check this is true
for all possible products but as an
example i will show here
that p132 times p213
is equal to p312
to see this act with the left hand side
on a basis
state we first apply this permutation
and we get this where i am using the
move the boxes view
we then rearrange to bring the terms to
the standard order before applying the
next permutation
we then act with the second permutation
and we get this
and finally we rearrange again
acting with the right hand side p312 on
the same basis state
we get this we can again rearrange to
get this
comparing both results here and here we
see that both terms are the same
confirming the product above the third
and final property of a group is the
existence of an inverse for every
element
with calculations like in this example
here we can show that the inverses of
the group elements are given by these
other group elements listed here
as i said earlier if you're not familiar
with group theory that's fine
all we need moving forward in our study
of quantum mechanics is what is called
the rearrangement theorem
imagine we order all group elements in a
list like this
for an n-particle system we have n
factorial permutation operators and the
list goes from 1 to n factorial
i am using again the notation in which
the sub index is a label for a
particular permutation rather than the
specific permutation
now if i pick an arbitrary group element
say p alpha
and multiply every element of the group
by p alpha i get a new list of group
elements like this
what the rearrangement theorem says is
that this second list contains each
element of the group
once and only once so this operation of
multiplying by an arbitrary group
element simply rearranges the order of
the elements but doesn't lead to
repeated elements
another way of putting this is that both
these lists have all
n factorial elements but simply in a
different order
as i said earlier for our purposes all
you need to remember about permutation
operators from these last two slides
is what the rearrangement theorem says
so don't worry we haven't encountered
group theory before
permutations play a central role when
studying systems of quantum identical
particles
you're now ready to learn about exciting
topics including exchange degeneracy
bosons and fermions all the way to
second quantization
if you like the video or would like to
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe